what happens to navalny what are the
possible conclusions of what you said
quite possibly the second most
influential powerful figure in russia
uh is there is he going to die in in
jail will he become the next president
of russia
well what are the possible i wish i knew
lex i've been surprised that he's still
alive
i've been worried
that he will be killed in prison in a
staged fight
you know some yes um a security officer
prison guard
puts on a prison outfit takes a lead
pipe goes into the cell they have a
quote fight
and navalny is killed i've been afraid
of that but he's still alive even though
he's serving a long sentence
so that leads me to guess
that people inside the putin regime and
maybe president putin himself understand
that navalny is their ticket to lift
sanctions
that navalny is
even more popular outside of russia than
he is inside of russia you know he's the
leader
in many ways of the up political
opposition in the country
even while still in prison his
organization's been destroyed
but it's he doesn't have majority
support in the population by any stretch
of the imagination but he's a big figure
in the west
including here in the us
and so navalny could be their ticket
they're kind of g
get out of jail card meaning they
release him from prison
he gets appointed i don't know prime
minister even by the putin regime if he
were willing to accept such a position
and i have my doubts about that
and then that's how they lobby
to remove the sanctions against them so
he's a card that president putin could
play
and so maybe that's the reason he's
still alive or maybe there are other
reasons that we don't know
and so
some alternative to putin is more likely
to arise
inside his gang
putin
as they say right inside his gang
where they tire
of his mistakes
they tire of his self-defeating actions
and they say patriotically for russia
we need to do something against move
against this guy
because
he's hurting our country and also
because i could do better
i'm ambitious as well as patriotic
but once again the problem there lex is
putin is surrounded by this cocoon
known as the fso
he's he meets on zoom
predominantly with the rest of the
government including with the defense
and security officials
they don't have
frequent access to his person
and as you were alluding
earlier to the pandemic they have to
quarantine for two weeks before every
meeting with him
and moreover you know lex
they don't know where he is
you see when they're on zoom with him
and
and the room
it's the valdai
his office in the valdai region looks
the same
as his office in sochi
or his office outside of moscow and nova
gary over there made up to look very
similar on zoom
and sure some signs they're looking
where is it but
maybe they don't know
and so you're gonna move on him
and you're gonna jump him in his kremlin
out his dacha
outside outside moscow
and it turns out he's in sochi or vice
versa and it turns out the fso is loyal
to him and and won't let you anyway so
lex we don't know but we watch this fso
really closely and we think that the the
elites if not putin but maybe putin to
understand navalny as a really big
potential political card that they could
play
you